in minnesota family members of dante
wright are angry and questioning the
justice system yesterday former police
officer kim potter was sentenced to two
years in prison for fatally shooting
wright last april after potter used her
gun instead of her taser during a
traffic stop david schuman of our
minneapolis station wcco tv reports
i have to live in this nightmare
watching my son shot and killed over
and over again
through tears katie wright pleaded for
the former police officer kim potter to
get the maximum sentence for killing her
son she never once said his name
and for that i'll never be able to
forgive you
potter who had been on the force for 26
years was convicted of first degree
manslaughter two days before christmas
[Music]
potter says she meant to tase right
during a traffic stop last april
but pulled her gun instead shooting
right once in the chest when her time to
speak came a tearful potter looked
directly at
i understand the mother's love
and i am sorry i broke your heart
officer potter made a mistake
that ended tragically
in the end judge regina chu her voice
cracking said potter would serve 24
months a quarter of what she faced
she never intended to hurt anyone
wright's family disappointed with the
sentence this lady
got a slap on the wrist and we still
every night
sitting around crying
waiting on my sons to come home
under minnesota law potter will only
have to serve two-thirds of her sentence
in prison 16 months meaning she could be
released almost exactly two years after
dante wright's death for cbs saturday
morning david schuman minneapolis